hi I'm Jason Martinez from Wolfram Alpha
and I'll be presenting on how to
manipulate units physical quantities and
equations in the Wolfram language
I'm Jason Martinez I'll be talking to
you about manipulating units physical
quantities and equations Wolfram
language alright so now the Wolfram
language contains thousands of units
over 25,000 units that includes things
like feet and ohms and moles as well as
compound units meters per second that
sort of thing and it also handles over
3,000 physical quantities these are the
things that those units are measuring
and we're in the process of making those
physical quantities compliant with the
ISO 80,000 and you should be seeing some
of that in the conference build and we
hope by the release of 12 that we'll
have all of that in there and we also
have a wide range of functions
continuing to add to for manipulating
these funky x' quantities and physical
quantities so just quick overview
hopefully this isn't too small for
anyone a little bit bigger so make
quantities just magnitude and units so
one kelvins difference and we have
somebody's formatting for all of those
and in terms of their typical of
[Music]
revs:1940rpm
m and a physical quantity mass if you
don't include an identifier you'll will
just use the physical quantity itself as
as that symbol and the natural language
processing here is really nice because
you can find the standard names pretty
quickly so if you wanted to find current
for instance you didn't know it was
electric current you can just do control
equals and and quickly get that as a
quantity variable and then go and add
whatever symbol you want
we also have included a lot of ways for
you to specify your own units and
physical quantities so I mean we have
independent units and physical
quantities so you can say that you have
some physical quantity of widgets and so
we can use that as a quantity variable
it will format nicely you could use it
in our other functions you can find the
canonical unit of widgets which will be
an independent unit you could use that
in turn in a quantity and then
manipulate things so you could have you
divide widgets by widgets over time and
find how long it took to make five
widgets and you can also find their
their unit dimensions which I'll talk a
bit more in a little bit but we also
have a lot of functions for translating
between quantity variables and
quantities and these unit dimension
lists so how do we do that so easy parts
are just getting the parts so finding
the magnitude of a quantity the the unit
we have dedicated functions quantity
magnitude Qui unit we can do the same
thing for physical quantities in that
case we're talking about the identifier
what that that that quantity variable
looks like the V here which could be
could be a string it could be some
subscripted expression could be whatever
you want and you can also get the
physical quantity straightforwardly
where things get interesting is when we
want to look at getting more information
so you know dimension lists are lists of
ordered dimension pairs where the first
first item is the is a unit dimension so
something like mass or length or money
and the second number is the degree to
which that unit or physical quantity has
in that dimension so calories for
instance has dimensions of length mass
and time because it's its energy has
length squared mass to the first power
time to the minus two and more
straightforwardly perhaps kelvins
difference over miles has unit
dimensions of minus one length units and
one temperature deference unit and we
can do the same thing for physical
quantities but the function in this case
is a little bit a little bit more power
than unit dimensions you know dimension
works on quantities and units my
variable dimensions works on both
quantity variables but also expressions
that include quantity variables so if we
wanted to find the quantity variable
dimensions of mass times a quantity
speed of light squared we can do that
again we have energy there and we can do
things like a derivative so here we have
some function that has dimensions of
radiant flux density or it visible wide
radiant flux density and it's a function
of time so if we skip ahead here we can
see what those you know dimensions are
and so if we expect that if we take the
Y variable dimensions of that expression
we should get the same thing but one
lower in time is the case and this will
work much more complex expressions too
now this next example unfortunately will
not work on my laptop but it will work
on the conference build is in version 12
and that is a quantum variable canonical
unit so that works that finds the
canonical unit for quantity variable and
in version 12 that will work on the
exact same things as quantity variable
dimensions so you'll be able to extract
do combinations of quantity variables
and also derivatives and that case will
be looking at what the so for this
example here we'd be finding the
canonical value unit for pressure and
dividing it by second so so Pascal
squared divided by seconds or in this
case it would be Pascal's divided by the
canonical unit for altitude which I
believe is meters yes now I didn't
highlight it here but you can also get
from unit dimension lists to units as
well so you have to make use of a hidden
way for defining your quantity variables
so you can define them in terms of unit
dimension lists so here we have we're
saying are our physical quantity is
basically has dimensions of length to
the minus three-halves and time to the
minus one and everything will work just
fine with that
including canonical unit and that case
it will construct a canonical unit in
terms of meters and seconds so the a
base SI units so that leaves us with the
missing piece how do we get from units
back to dimensions as we can do
dimension to physical coins how do we
get because we can do physical coins to
units how do we get back again and
that's the function that we're in the
process of developing which we're
calling a physical quantity lookup so
that will take a quantity or a unit or
combination of those and return a list
of physical quantities because every
units going to correspond to a number of
different physical quantities to
altitude and width and distance and so
forth this is not necessarily how it's
going to be ordered in the list we're
still discussing that maybe that we will
wait it towards what's more more
frequently asked about but
if you have a strong opinion on that
please let us know but we will have a
second argument for limiting this to
should be an option alphabetical versus
popular popular
all right yeah
well I mean I think that may be a good
idea we can I'll look into that
all right so moving along and so this
will work on combinations as well
example down there and it also of course
work with you know dimensionless because
that lets us complete this diagram and
work with independent units though in
that case we'll probably have to
construct some combination of physical
quantities to return something that
actually matches a physical quantity all
right so let's move on to how
manipulating these expressions along
unit dimensions so the first of the two
functions I want to talk about here is
dimensional combinations so this is a
function that takes a list of physical
quantities or quantity variables and
constructs the combination of those that
yields a dimensionless expression so we
know Ohm's law so via so you can see
that that expression there is going to
be have no dimension overall you can
also include a second argument so here
we have energy squared times the
electric potential difference divided by
mass and we have all these other
parameters and we get an expression that
will match the dimensions of this of
this other of the second argument you
can also include your own include
quantities so perhaps you have some
physical constants that are important
and whatever you're looking at and so
this is a way for sort of figuring out
what what what
expressions will will match others that
other things so if you have trying to
find something that balances your
equation you can find some options and
dimensional combination you can also
find of course dimensionless numbers
which are a useful way to characterize
systems without having to concern
yourself with whatever units that other
people maybe be looking at so here's an
example where we take a few parameters
of interest - fluid mechanics so things
like surface tension density speed that
sort of thing as well as some known
dimensionless numbers that we can get
from formula data and we can put in
these quantity variables in
two-dimensional combinations and it gets
us a long list but we can also see we
can also see how we could construct
these already discovered dimensionless
numbers from those dimensional
combinations and almost all the cases
it's just simply taking one of those
solution solutions to a power so
Archimedes numbers at the eighth
solution from our list to the third
power well there's one solution the
brown well can snubber where we take the
third solution this one and the
thirteenth solution somewhere down here
squared and that gets us our
dimensionless number and we could apply
this to all sorts of things recently
there was recently last year there was a
paper in the field of economics looking
at dimensionless price impact functions
so they had a number of physical
qualities that they had constructed
stock price was just money per share
that size trading volume stock
volatility that cost and so they were
they took these found a dimensional
combination that worked and were able to
analyze that so let's just generate that
that number
so if we don't specify that we don't
want generated parameters generated
parameters none it'll give us a general
solution to the for the dimensional
combinations any value of c1 or c2 that
we put up here will yield a
dimensionless expression but if we
specify the generated parameters none
we'll get the lowest order solutions and
we can see that we can construct the
number the expressions they got out of
these general solutions so this is just
the reciprocal of their first
expressions the reciprocal of that third
solution to the with the cubic root and
their second expression is just that
combined with the first solution now the
other function that we have for dealing
with transforming expressions is non
dimensionalization transform and this
lets you transform an equation by
removing any dimensions from the
quantity variables within that equation
so here we have a quantum harmonic
oscillator equation and we have a whole
host of quantity variables but once we
non dimensionalize it will only have two
at the end so we're going to specify the
two that we want at the end we have sy
and our X here and we also specify what
the symbols we want to have in our final
solution if we didn't specify that it
would still solve it it would just
create its own generated parameters to
fill the gaps and we can also get the
rules that get us from the original
equation to this equation there are
other arguments for getting the reverse
of those rules and what the various
factors involved are and another nice
feature of non dimensionalization
transform is that we've also included
natural units so this is the case where
the physicist says that we're going to
treat H bar and C equal to one
so we can use this to make our final
expressions that much more clear so here
we're going to pull formula from formula
data for the surface gravity of a
charged spinning black hole and we feed
that into non dimensionalization
transform and we get an expression which
doesn't have any quantity variables but
it does have this ugly scaling factor
there but if we specify that we want our
results into sitter units which seems
appropriate use it involving black holes
then we get this in terms of the
cosmological constant and we can compare
how these natural units work on
different formulas here's just a simple
example looking at Coulomb's law and the
law of gravitation looking just that the
forces involved now we apply these to
the different these the natural units to
the different equations and we can see
how they they compare some move the
factor in factors involved entirely
others yield some numerical number that
then has to be accounted for and that's
because different units are optimized
for different fields we tried to get a
fairly comprehensive list of natural
units to incorporate into not non
dimensionalization transform alright so
where else we're using physical
quantities and units there's of course
plots and solve that we're working on
getting better and better usage of but
there's also a lot of entity domains so
one of them is physical constants this
has we introduced this late last year
and it contains over 200 constants from
physics and chemistry and so forth and
provides information on those constants
things like the speed of light or the
electric constant
and so you can look at different
properties of them what their names are
and their values their their their how
how certain we are about them and we can
also look at different sets of physical
constants from in terms of their the
physical quantities involved mass or
energy or the field so astronomical
constants or cosmological constants and
you can convert these entities into
quantities that you can then use or the
reverse this is useful if you want to
look at what the numbers inside your
equations mean we also have course have
formula data you talk a little bit more
about things coming in formative data in
a moment here's a little hidden thing
that should work in your conference
build I think maybe 11 3 let me see yes
but we'll be documenting soon is just
bringing it into alignment with the rest
of the language in supporting
Association there are other domains that
are making use of quantity variable such
as the physical systems which contains
all sorts of systems like various
quantum systems we have the vendor van
der Waal gas equations and so forth
another example here is what's I'm too
far measurement devices so these this is
a domain that describes or contains data
on a wide range of measuring devices
their range of applicability their
relation to other measuring devices and
you can query them based on their their
physical quantities and the other thing
that's coming which got mentioned
earlier in the week is the formula
repository so
is a website where people will be able
to submit their formulas for it to be
added at the moment is consisting mostly
of formulas that we already have in the
language but trying to incorporate
information on different physical
quantities I mean they'll probably the
formulas examples using the meta
information we're available of about who
created them and when there we go and
with the introduction of the function
repository will be also expanding that
to make use of that repository so that
we can tackle within formula data more
interesting cases like very complicated
empirical formulas or formulas that are
not just algebraic but actually have
some some differential component and
also coming up there'll be just a minor
footnote here of known physical quantity
q which will be allow you to check
physical quantities make sure that
they're valid and we also want to make
sure get either either unit convert to
work with natural units or create its
own another function that allow you to
translate quantities into natural units
so you can see how for example what is
uh what is the mass of a whale in plunk
units or something of that sort or maybe
more usefully different subatomic
particles and that brings me to the end
I'll take any questions